hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the gold money asian rapid
knockouts uh it's
the battle for third place and it's
magnus cross and versus dingler in a
match uh
well a lot of you thought would be the
the match for the first place but it's
not
because even though magnus and dean both
won their uh first match against
levon and artemyev uh both levon and
artemia were able to bounce back
uh win the second match and then win in
tie break so
uh there it was an incredible day for
for both of them
and now magnus and being need to roll it
out for third place so let's see what
happened that this is game one of their
match and it's uh
it's quite an enjoyable one so magnus
with the white pieces
opens with c4 we have knight to f6 by
being
knight to c3 ended now e5 going for the
uh two nights variation of the english
uh we have e3
and now knight to c6 the so-called
reverse sicilian line of the english
queen to b3 and now comes bishop to b4
and already this is a new move
uh so already as of move four we have a
completely new game
yeah pretty incredible stuff we have
knight to d5 magnus tries to take
advantage of the weirdly placed bishop
here
and only now dean shifts the bishop back
to c5 instead of that bishop to b4
uh most people just developed the bishop
to c5 right away but okay
ding has a plan we have d3 uh and now uh
castles we have knight to f3 and the d6
now preparing to develop the light
square bishop
knight back to c3 now magnus wants to
shift this knight over to e4 and
knight to e7 now now you can play c6
maybe striking the center with the d5
we have bishop to e2 and now knight to
g6 we have castles by magnus and
now rook to e8 and here bishop to d2 now
you can see that magnus is playing a
very slow maneuvering game
uh so taking a very cautious approach
against being in round one with
h6 and now rook d1
uh we have bishop to b6 now that the
rook is here you might
move the bishop execute d4 at some point
so the bishop is safer here on b6 but
also you can just develop your light
square bishop so your b7 pawn will not
be hanging
so here knight the e4 and here magnus is
offering a chance for dink to double his
pawns but if ding does this
uh then yes you've doubled his pawns but
then magnus will have uh
well in an eternal grip on the d5 square
you will not be able to
to cross it and uh well these pawns are
controlling
these squares very nicely so it's uh
it's not all that bad
but you could play it for example knight
h4 then we trade captures captures and
it's uh it's a pretty fine position for
black
but the ding doesn't like it he plays c6
instead he prepares his d5 idea now
bishop to c3 now and uh knight to h7
uh we're here with with some ideas of
maybe executing f5 maybe trying to push
maybe the knight is coming to g5 so you
know that all depends on what white
plays of course you do not want to play
f5 while the queen is here
otherwise just uh you know c5 and you
lose the bishop
so here we have bishop to b4 this is a
very interesting move because it
hones in on the d6 pawn which is a
backward spawn
uh and uh uh you you don't really have a
good way of defending it you could play
c5 but that looks a bit weird closing in
your dark square bishop like this so
ding just advances it's the the other
pawn to d5 so here we have cactus
captures and now knight to d6 attacking
the rook and the bishop here
uh being just that moves the rook we
have rooked the e6 and now
knight captures in c8 rook captures and
now rook a to c1
so with this little maneuver it seems
that magnus was
able to activate both of these rooks so
it's uh not bad because ding had
problems developing that light square
bishop
and bringing the rook into the game we
have knight back to f6 biting
and now g3 weakening the king's position
a little bit but you are keeping those
knights at bay
so here rook to c7 ding is preparing to
double up on the c
file trying to uh do some damage here
and bishop to f1 now magnus says
that's not a problem i'm just going to
re-maneuver my bishop to this long
diagonal
we have queen to c8 now threatening to
win material with rook captures on c1 so
magnus trades here we have captures
captures and now
bishop to c3 so now the e pawn is being
pressured so
rook to e8 but instead of rook to e8 you
don't really have a good move here for
black
the position is fine but you have to
play very passively there's
not all that much you can do here uh so
ding has to
try something he plays rook to e8 maybe
he can you know shift the rook over to
c8 if this bishop ever moves but
you know just giving the move to magnus
so rook the c1 now threatening to win
some material
uh okay not for the moment the rook here
is not defended but you are
eyeing that queen so you know better
just move the queen so queen to d7
uh and now bishop to g2 so
uh just slowly but surely improving the
position we have queen to
f5 by ding and now rook to d1 defending
that
d3 pawn uh we have e for now by ding and
here
uh ding is uh you know enjoying his
position he's very happy he was able to
execute this e4 push
but magnus not not all that worried he
plays pawn captures we have pawn
captures and knights to d2 and here
uh ding goes knight to g4 uh there was a
there was a better idea than knight to g
for knight the e5 with the threat of
knight f3
seems to be much scarier and here white
would maybe have to give up he's a very
strong dark square bishop
uh but uh you know uh it's it's hard to
find everything in a rapid game so here
being played knight to g4 he put
pressure on this f2 pawn
but now magnus just defends it rook to
f1 and he doesn't care
he says ding has nothing here yes there
are a lot of pieces here in front of my
king the bishop is on a very nice
diagonal
but i'm not worried about anything and
here uh things should continue
uh with something like uh well it's not
an easy position for ding but he should
probably play something like knight to
e5
but even that doesn't really help him
yes you go after this f3 pawn but just
queen to a4 attacks the rook and now
there's a triple attack on this spawn
and you don't have time for knight to f3
check you you won't be you will not
have time to capture back because the
rook here is hanging so
ding uh considers this but he says nope
there's a there's a much better move and
he plays
knight captures on f2 we've reached the
position from the thumbnail
and this is a pretty scary idea uh
if it worked but it doesn't so it's not
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not doing anything weird like rook
captures on f2 if you capture this then
bishop captures an e3
just uh wins the game there is no way to
defend this rook here and black will
just have a you know
a much better position uh and for those
of you who founded this
incredible knight to c4 then
congratulations you
really are uh uh well an impressive
player
uh so this uh this move is uh incredible
because now
there's the thread of rook captures
knight the knight here is just silly and
the knight on c4 is preventing the
bishop from capturing the e3 pawn
while also attacking the bishop so here
ding really doesn't have a good reply to
this the knight will fall and you don't
have an answer to this
uh ding tried knight to h3 check but
there's a second problem here
now that uh he moves the knight look at
this the rook
and the queen are attacking the f7 pawn
and that's a huge problem now
magnus just happily captures he wins a
piece and now
ding doesn't really have an option he
captures an h3 but now magnus just
removes the bishop from b6 and opens up
the queen's attack to the f7 pawn and it
was in this position on move 32 that the
english and resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you've just lost a piece and if you
accept
the knight here with a capture some b6
we just play queen captures on f7 check
king here or h7 and then this is
checkmate so
that's not playable and other than that
you don't really have a move this is
being threatened you can defend it but
then we just bring the knight back into
the game we're up a piece where
we enjoy a much better position and now
the position is completely
winning we have well like i said there's
an extra piece the bishop is a monster
and
there there's simply no compensation
here for them so
uh ding had a very very interesting game
magnus played very cautiously and in the
end it paid out the ding tried to
attacking attacking attacking he i guess
he was uh
bored already with with slow maneuvering
uh he
you know came with magnus and magnus was
ready with
this incredibly impressive knight to c4
id
really really awesome stuff because it
just uh you know attacks the
e3 pawn and that's it there's nothing to
be done so
after knight captures on b6 being
resigned and the magnus wins game one
and for those of you who are interested
what happened in the other games
i don't know if i'll be i'll have time
to cover them i will now mention it so
don't listen if you're not interested
uh after magnus won the third the first
game uh all the three games that
followed ended in a draw
which means that magnus uh wins the
first match
so magnus is the first match we'll see
what happens tomorrow after we check out
the
the finals between levon and artemyev
we're going to check out under this
match as well
so a very very very nice game i hope you
guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank lance hassan
connor clark james walker peter milner
and wolfgang schmidt for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend